waouw c'est magnifique ces grands de
grandeur les premiers visiteurs à
pénétrer ce samedi matin dans le bol ont
eu l'impression de découvrir un nouveau
monde une forêt vierge sous cet immense
verrière de 8000 mètres carrés comme une
balade sous les tropiques qui permet de
découvrir près de 200 espèces
c'est assez haut c'est à ces grands noms
déjà on n'a pas l'impression d'être
enfermé à l'intérieur d'eux
nice hier on va dire et donc il ya une
multitude de végétation diverses variées
donc c'est assez incroyable
on a l'impression d'être sous les
tropiques on est
l'impression de voyager et puis vraiment
avec la végétation
et vraiment émergé comme si on se
balader en cours et et convoyait des
animaux à proximité
ses très grands mais
mais on s'y fait si beaucoup d espèce
tropicale était déjà présente dans le
zoo de beauval leur regroupement dans
cet immense aire va demander aux
soigneurs une prise en compte de
beaucoup plus de paramètres plus proche
du milieu naturel qui va falloir surtout
s'habituer ici passées à travailler avec
en collaboration avec les soigneurs du
dôme qui des maquis apprennent eux aussi
à appréhender leur univers là et puis
que nous on apprenne aussi voilà comment
on va pouvoir approcher telle ou telle
espèce dans le cadre du dôme dans la
halle architecture des enclos dans la
disposition des loges de nuit donc il ya
un travail en fait d'apprentissage comme
on a à chaque fois qu'on crée un nouvel
enclos de si on doit attraper son doigt
anesthésiée comment on va s'y prendre
un nouvel espace apte aussi à attirer
les touristes en toute saison
dans une ambiance toujours tropicale